what do you think of when you first hear
the word mutant do you immediately
imagine cool supernatural powers sure
these powers might make people meet in
some comic books but did you know that
in our world we are all mutants so what
do we mean when we say the word mutant
and what is a mutation to answer this
question we need to go back to the
beginning of human life the union of egg
and sperm cells since both egg and sperm
cells contain DNA we inherit half of our
own DNA from each parent all of the DNA
in a single person's body is called
their genome and to find out how unique
we really are we have to compare our
genomes to our parents genomes DNA is
basically a set of instructions that our
cells use to build proteins which act
like the cogs and wheels with them
cell's proteins influence the way our
bodies appear function and respond to
our environment the DNA instructions for
building proteins are spelled out using
four molecules called nucleotides a C T
and G for short these nucleotides are
the key to mutations to be exact a
mutation is a change in nucleotides and
it automatically translates to a change
in the protein product think of it like
a blueprint when you change the
instructions the final design will
change accordingly most mutations occur
during cell division when a mother cell
fully duplicates its DNA so that each of
its daughter cells can receive a copy
occasionally it mistakes can occur and
one copy of DNA that gets passed down
might be slightly different from the
others the DNA that contains the error
is called the mutated DNA DNA mutations
can occur in two different ways somatic
mutations occur in a person cells during
their lifetime and do not get passed
down to future offspring for example
smoking can cause somatic mutations
which lead to cancer and lung diseases
hereditary mutations on the other hand
are locked into your genes from the
moment you're born that's because they
occur in a sperm or egg cell of your
parent before or shortly after they fuse
into an embryo
the first cell that makes you hereditary
mutations are transmitted to you and
your children because your embryo
becomes the template for all of your
cell development when a hereditary
mutation happens for the first time in
your embryo it's called de novo which
means new because it didn't exist in
your parents
a recent study estimates that every one
of us is born with about sixty de novo
mutations on the other hand you may
inherit old hereditary mutations from
your ancestors both old and new
hereditary mutations will be passed down
to future generations each adding to the
genetic variation within a population
genetic variation consists of the unique
family traits or characteristics of a
certain population within a certain
geographical region and it's the reason
we're not exactly the same as our
relatives there is no one else in this
whole world who has the exact same
genome as yours all thanks to mutations
most hereditary mutations are neutral as
far as we can tell they have no
observable impact on health or outer
appearance mutations are an inherent
part of life so why do we need them if
mutations did not occur we wouldn't have
any new genetic variation after a while
everyone would be made up of a singular
dominant genome this would be fine as
long as our environment stayed the same
but our environment is fickle and nature
selects which random mutations helped us
survive as the world changes around us
this is how evolution works and it
depends on the genetic variation
provided by mutation without genetic
variation we wouldn't be able to adapt
to environmental changes so our
mutations don't necessarily give us cool
super powers but now you know they give
us the power to survive
you